[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le 7-8
loisirs toutes vos idées sorties
culturelles ou ludiques dans le
département merci de nous retrouver pour
ce nouveau numéro de tout de suite le
sommaire de ce vendredi 17 novembre jeux
de rôles jeux vidéo ou de figurines ce
week-end c'est la troisième édition du
festival du jeu de villepreux amateurs
ou spécialistes sont invités en famille
ou entre amis le responsable de cet
événement sera avec vous pour vous en
parler
la guerre des théâtres et déclaré à
versailles une pièce qui regroupe avec
humour et un côté burlesque de théâtre
marionnettes et opéra un mélange des
genres jouer jusqu'au 26 novembre au pea
troupes en afrique
enfin mettez vous dans la peau d'un
détective à vélizy la médiathèque
organise un festival sur le thème du
polar
les plus jeunes sont invités en kit et
mélanie a ramené les indices
[Musique]
le festival saint quentin qui met à
l'honneur le film documentaire se
poursuit jusqu'à dimanche
la thématique de cette troisième édition
la musique une programmation riche et
variée de documentaires mais aussi de
concerts et d'ateliers est à retrouver
sur le site internet trois bourgs 3w
50-1 point fr jeudi 16 novembre c'est le
coeur des enfants du conservatoire de
maurepas qui s'est produit sur la scène
de l'espace albert camus les 100 élèves
ont interprété des chansons enfantines
et des chants du monde
créé il ya un an c'était l'un des
premiers concerts du coeur d'autres sont
à venir
on écoute ce leur professeur et un élève
au micro de mélanie poké on a un
programme cette année qui sera donné en
juin sur musiques du monde
donc vous avez entendu une berceuse
chinoise et une batucada qui se voulait
être des percussions brésiliennes
c'est important de pouvoir se donner en
public donc c'est vraiment une chance de
pouvoir montrer qu'on sait faire quelque
chose
moi en tant que pédagogue c'est un moyen
aussi de stimuler mes troupes
c'est à musique en fête au tout début
ben je veux commencer les cours de piano
et et ça et c'était bien comme je
voulais apprendre à chanter des trucs
comme ça aussi
eh ben mes parents m'ont inscrit au
conservatoire
[Musique]
bien avec nous festival du jeu laisse
tomber la téloche rendez vous à du pr
[Musique]
gars tout ce qu'on veut au festival du
jeu pour les petits les grands de 7 à
104 ans jeux de société jeux vidéos
animations
restauration
miam viens avec nous au festival du jeu
c'est un festival un régal viens avec
tes festival du jeu
bref merci beaucoup s'ils n'ont remarqué
alors comme vous pouvez le constater on
reste dans la musique mais surtout dans
le jeu avec notre invité alors vous êtes
entendre si vous remarquez responsable
de la médiathèque
le nautilus de villepreux nous a fait
part de ses talents artistiques pour
nous présenter le festival du jeu qui
commence samedi 18 novembre bravo à vous
et merci d'être avec nous c'est gentil
merci madame
alors vous avez composer vous même un
cette petite chanson alors pour nous
parler de cet événement d'importance
dont vous êtes l'organisateur c'est la
troisième édition
c'est la troisième édition cette année
toujours solide de notre élu aux loisirs
olivier coaching qui pilote l'événement
et on a donc remis cette fois ci encore
en ébullition tout le tout l'espace
mimoune qui est un grand complexe
sportif à villepreux pour permettre aux
gens de s'amuser pendant deux jours et
ça va être à mon avis assez réussi voilà
alors au niveau de l'organisation à
plusieurs espaces thématiques ont été
mis en place
absolument donc il ya un espace
principal un espace qui fait environ
1000 mètres carrés
c'est vraiment l'espace où les gens vont
pouvoir déambuler et découvrir ou
retrouver des gens qu'ils connaissent
pas ce qu'il ya aussi bien des jeux d
adresse des jeux de bois que des jeux de
rôles que les gens ne connaissent pas
forcément bien il y a deux îlots des
boutiques
les boutiques sont venus en force cette
année ce qui fait que en avance sur la
période de noël là les gens vont pouvoir
essayer s'amuser rêver dans leur jeu
puis hachez repartir avec les jeux s'ils
veulent on a donc bien sûr des jeux de
société de toutes sortes d'éditeurs
plein de bénévoles et d'associations qui
sont venus avec nous est un espace
photos de prototypes qui continuent de
gonfler qui permet de montrer que les
jeux de société c'est aussi de la
création un espace prototype
qu'est ce que c'est c'est ce qu'on
appelle entre nous une proto zone c'est
à dire qu'un jeu de société ça se
construit à partir d'une idée
après il faut le tester il faut tester
ce qu'on appelle aussi des mécaniques de
jeu des feux de mécanique de
fonctionnement ensuite il faut
travailler avec par exemple des corps de
métiers artistiques comme kiva
l'illustré qu'est-ce qu'on veut lui
donner comme ton etc et toute cette
élaboration là ça prend du temps c'est
des choses qui sont
qui sont des choses fait avec beaucoup
de beaucoup de qualités artistiques je
trouve moi et donc la proto zone c'est
un moment où le jeu n'est pas terminée
c'est un moment où le jeu et avec un
matériel qui est en fête artisanale par
exemple ou alors il a un des jeux de la
proto zone qui est quasiment terminée
qui est magnifique déjà bien tester en
avant-première en fait on fait des
avant-premières voilà exactement et des
jeux de la proto zone de l'année
dernière sont maintenant dans la zone
des jeux qui sont édités super donc il
faudra venir tester il y en aura en plus
pour tous les âges il n'y a pas d'âge
pour s'amuser en plus de cet espace
principal on a un espace jeunesse qui
est assez grand avec d'une part dans
l'espace qui possède les grands tatami
l'espace dojo du du complexe
l'association le tourbillon avec un
grand château gonflable et puis tout un
tas de jeux pour les plus petits
et ensuite nous zone à côté avec des
jeux pour lui un peu plus grand et là
aussi il ya une boutique qu'elle sera
présente donc on a vraiment réussi à
avoir pour pour la jeunesse quelque
chose aussi d'assez pertinent je pense
et enfin on à la zone jeu vidéo qui
cette année est une non pas orientée sur
le rétro gaming gaming comme le sort les
années précédentes mais qui est sûr les
jeux next gen enfin sur le jour
d'aujourd'hui il y aura fifa 18 il
renferme en effet ça va être bourré de
monde 7 7
donc on a en un prestataire là qui a mis
le paquet ça va être à mon avis très
très percutant et on peut venir déguisés
aussi surtout venez déguisés venez
déguisés venait fait divisée au festival
du jeu parce que ça c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui permet de donner le
petit peuple qu'on aime bien avoir sur
ce festival qui garde son caractère
convivial quoi sympathique entre les oui
alors comment vous est venue l'idée de
créer ce festival un événement qui a
quand même bien marché les deux
dernières années vous avez accueilli du
monde
oui mais oui c'est un festival
l'année dernière on peut estimer qu'on
eut quelque chose de l'ordre de 3500
visiteurs on peut estimer 2500 visiteurs
uniques c'est à dire que c'est quand
même assez assez honorable pour une
deuxième édition cette idée elle est
venue tout simplement parce que moi au
niveau de la médiathèque le nautilus à
villepreux je désire que le jeu de
société soit mis en avant parce que je
pense que ça fait partie des des formes
culturelles modernes qui sont un peu un
peu facile non mais sur le côté alors
qu'en réalité
même s'il ya bien sûr une un commerce et
une activité sociale autour de tout ça
c'est une activité qui une activité
d'abord je trouve intelligente et qui
est une école morize les changes aussi
exactement voilà ce qui me plaît le plus
c'est que c'est quelque chose qui permet
une bonne intelligence
être ensemble c'est ce que je préfère
est un dernier mot alors sur les infos
pratiques donc l'entrée est accessible
donc là on voit l'entrée est libre en
fait injure à seulement la restauration
sur place à payer plus une tombola
également voilà il ya une tombola dont
ces petites nouveautés cette année avec
un premier prix cro magnon qui est un
jeu de bioviva qui est un de nos
nombreux partenaires et donc 7 cette
année il y aura beaucoup de food truck
sur les deux jours qui permettront aux
gens de se restaurer pendant les deux
jours de jeux vidéo vont s'épuiser à
jouer donc un dernier mot très rapide on
va rappeler juste le lieu et les
horaires le lieu c'est le complexe
sportif alain mimoun et les horaires
c'est le samedi de 14 heures à minuit et
le dimanche de 10h à 18h parfait super
merci beaucoup donc à ne pas manquer
pour vous amuser entre amis ou en
famille de tout le week end
plus de détails sont disponibles sur le
site internet de vie pro merci beaucoup
si vous remarquez pour ce petit live
nous allons présenter votre événement
merci à vous une véritable guerre se
joue dès ce week end à versailles
jusqu'au 26 novembre un opéra-comique
mise en scène par jean philippe jean
philippe desrousseaux une oeuvre pour
célébrer les deux cent quarante ans du
théâtre montansier elle a été coproduite
par l'opéra comique et le centre de
musique baroque de versailles
découverte avec ce reportage de marie
pas naîtra
un humour burlesque deschamps et de
marionnettes utilisées pour se moquer
des genres théâtraux au xviiie siècle
les forains commentait déjà l'actualité
théâtrale avec l'opéra comique une
moquerie sur la grandiloquence de
certains genres par exemple on
caricature la comédie française dans ce
qu'elle a de plus outré de plus larges
dans ses références à la tragédie
antique et c'est en caricature l'opéra
qui focalisent sur des mots alors
qu'elle est en train de parler
la serrure vocalises sur une voyelle et
on voit les pauvres fera se moquait
aussi de ces gens là la guerre des
théâtres oeuvre au cadre historique
raconte l'histoire de forains jouant la
matrone d'ephèse jalouse la comédie
française vient interrompre la pièce et
l'opéra vise à interdire le champ
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une métaphore des guerres de théâtre à
cette période
tous les genres sont présents pantomime
opéra marionnettes et théâtre
un mélange acquis dès le xviiie siècle
c'est justement la force des comédiens
forains leur force leur imagination leur
inventivité pour contrer les
interdictions exercée par la colonie
française et l'opéra qui ont permis de
créer ce théâtre conte qu'on aimerait
aujourd'hui hybride la pièce plonge les
spectateurs dans le passé les décors
sont d'époque pain en 1836 par six
séries et boulay et l'éclairage fidèle
aux coutumes d'antan
pour compléter cette ambiance les
spectateurs peuvent venir habillés avec
des costumes d'époque
jusqu'au 26 novembre au théâtre
montansier à versailles
[Musique]
les adultes ont pas gata christie ou
harlan coben pour les plus jeunes c'est
plutôt anthony horowitz ou patrick
mosconi
ils sont tous auteurs de polars une
catégorie de livres très en vogue est à
l'honneur avec les îles villacoublay
bonjour mélanie un genre km jusqu'au 26
novembre les fans de romans policiers
vont pouvoir trouver leur bonheur à la
médiathèque de la commune avec en quête
de polars de nombreux rendez vous sont
proposés les adultes vont pouvoir
rencontrer des auteurs de romans et des
détectives et les enfants sont bien sûr
pas oublié mais avant de découvrir les
activités myriam graillot la responsable
du secteur adultes nous explique ce
qu'est un polar en général le roman le
policier ça commence souvent par un
meurtre donc le principe du roman
policier c'est de vivre en même temps
que les personnages la résolution d'une
enquête
qu'est ce qui plaît bien je pense c'est
le petit côté free sont inquiétants et
puis se dire de toute façon c'est une
fiction ça ne peut pas m'arriver à moi
donc c'est vivre un petit peu un petit
peu ce côté
voilà je frissonne j'ai peur et en même
temps ça m'accroche parce que j'ai envie
de savoir ce qui s'est passé
savoir ce qui s'est passé dans votre
livre mai à la médiathèque le public
veut être acteur le public va devoir
enquêter faire des analyses
écoutez des petites énigmes à résoudre
le personnel de la médiathèque ne va pas
leur faciliter la tâche parce qu'il va y
avoir aussi des codes à résoudre alors
pour les plus petits âgés de 3 ans une
activité proposée le dimanche 26
novembre à 11 heures avant de retrouver
les parents pour un brunch et des jeux
de société
alice bodin nous en dit un peu plus on
va leur faire une petite heure du conte
soirée thématique du polar d'aucune de
mes collègues à leur raconter leur
raconter des petites histoires de
détectives privés de mystère de
roquettes
on va leur proposer donc un atelier
scientifique qui sera donc réalisée par
l'association les savants fous dont tu
as posté c'est en fait qu'ils vont mener
languette ils vont devoir examiner des
preuves on sera des empreintes digitales
dentaire labiale alors les ateliers
scientifiques sont sur inscription pour
les 6 8 ans l'atelier est à 15 heures
pour les 9 12 ans et à 16h30
à noter pour les plus grands à partir de
13 ans une enquête interactive est
proposé avec une tablette et un casque
vous devrez découvrir qui a refroidi le
mort alors avis aux détectives dans
l'âme on compte sur vous pour ramener
des indices merci mélanie pour cette
découverte est on le rappelle vous avez
jusqu'au 26 novembre pour en profiter le
satis loisirs est maintenant terminé
merci de nous avoir suivi ce que vous
avez fait le plein d'idées sorties en
famille ou entre amis pour en profiter
tout le week-end je vous retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
et je vous souhaite un excellent week
end
m